you
the first element of trust is that
everybody feels that there's
transparency and there are obviously
conversations that have to take place in
a certain way and there are some things
that are just inappropriate to blurt out
but we basically know those that's not
what I'm talking about I'm talking about
being protective of information or
feeling like you have to create your
image with your board in order to leave
the the other board members feeling
confident the confidence comes from that
ultimately by the way all of the
confidence comes from the performance of
the company you can be the best showman
in the boardroom but in fact over time
if you're not producing results it
doesn't matter and the converse can be
true you can be a little kind of maybe
timid in the boardroom for whatever
reason maybe it's your personality but
you are you know you're getting results
that you know that's where the
confidence comes from the other place
where the comments come from is when
your board members see that you're
running an efficient meeting because
their time is valuable they know your
time is valuable they know the company
is invested in that in the in this
meeting and so when they see you coming
you're actually the structure of the
meeting and the way the meeting is run
and the way the people are giving a
chance persons having a chance to talk
the CEO is not doing too much talking
progress is being made that is another
way that a CEO can instill confidence
with their board but but I guess I guess
I the the the notion itself that you're
supposed to create confidence or project
confidence what you're really supposed
to do is add shareholder value and run
the company well and run the board
meeting well the rest will follow
if you leave those board meetings
consistently prepared to do something
different because you learned something
from the board meeting that's a mark of
a good board
if you dis and plenty of CEOs are this
way they they think a good board meeting
is when they leave and nobody got mad at
each other and every and they accepted
all their proposals I I don't I don't
feel that's the case because then the
board then the board just became
compliance so the first step is
diagnosing do I in fact have a good
board or not and I guess my point is
that some people's definition of a good
board is actually the opposite of what I
think is a good well-functioning board
then if you then but let's assume you
don't feel like you have a good
functioning board then you have a
question about is it the people or is it
the process if it's the people that's a
tough fix because you are gonna have to
turnover people in the board if it's the
process then I think the easiest advice
is to find seek someone either on your
board or outside your board and say I'm
just it's not working I mean I get these
really smart people and we all get along
and we show up on time but every time I
leave the board meeting I just don't
feel like I got any value out of it and
then you diagnose well how do you run
your meetings and what materials do you
send out and let me see the materials
and usually someone who's got some
experience will be able to diagnose it
and say here's your problems and if you
fix these things you'll fix your process
with a public company there's a lot of
regulations and rules around what you
can and can't do what you should do
there's things that have to take place
in board meeting largely all of those
don't exist in a small private company
secondly that the in a large public
company the board members are tend to
not be significant shareholders they may
own just you know tiny percent so if you
can imagine let's say the board of
Disney although you might have a few old
family members Beit from the Disney
family most of those shares are spread
among funds and other individual
investors so but with a small company
oftentimes the entire ownership group is
in the room or let's say 80% of the
ownership in the room so starting you
start with different demographics
secondly generally the CEO is at a
different stage in their growth so if
it's a mature company you're looking at
how do we grow 5% a year or how do we
make these little moves but with a small
or medium-sized company you're talking
you're trying to move in leaps and
that's that requires more of a
mentorship role from the board and there
so that you can to get more into
operating details and those are kinds of
some of the kinds of differences but
there are the there aren't the the
guidelines or the framework that exist
with public companies and private
companies so what oftentimes happens and
I think it's a failure of small boards
is that people kind of wing it and the
CEO wings it in terms of what she or he
writes in the board material and how the
and and then the board members kind of
show up and they're not quite sure well
where is the line between being helping
them with operations and then I'm
actually starting to supplant management
as opposed to supporting management so
those rules are generally not as clear
as they might be in a larger company
norms that are clear in a public company
are not necessarily clear in a
public/private company I'll give you an
example there are attendance rules with
public companies that are defined there
are no attendance rules that are defined
in a smaller medium-sized company
traditionally a non-profit board is a
collection of your large donors we're
people who can have access to large
donors and bring in money so it's really
a Development Board I think the world is
moving and they're moving the nonprofit
boards are moving more in the direction
of the for-profit boards which is that
we want operational strategic help but
in order to do that it can't just be the
people who write the big checks it has
to be people who understand operating
issues and understand the difference
between the operating issues of a
non-profit is versus a for-profit so the
problems that are occurring which I
think over time will get fixed is we
have our largest donors but they don't
know how to run businesses because of
where their money came from but they
were excellent as fundraisers but the
next is we have we have a wave of people
are coming in saying we're gonna run
nonprofits like for profits but the
problem is they don't run the same
because the metrics of success aren't
the same in a for-profit it's simple
over time more cash has to come in then
go out it's that simple
nonprofit is different their mission
driven and I like to think about the two
as in a for-profit your goal is to make
money
the mission is drives that so the
mission drives the financials nonprofits
exactly the opposite the financials
drive the mission and you need board
members that understand that
I think really the best boards are the
ones where the CEO has the competence in
themselves and in their direction that
they're free to talk about the things
that are worrying them that are
troubling them to say I have this issue
here that is keeping me awake at night
and I have to be honest with you I
really don't know which direction to go
and I'm hoping to take advantage of the
five of us being in the room to give me
some advice on what I should do here
that's a confident CEO a CEO that lacks
confidence is one that wants to protect
themselves and lead it and create an
image that they have all the answers but
of course they don't have all the
answers and by the way they're they're
fooling no one because the board members
know that nobody has all the answers